teach me dr. strange first trailer
premiered in a complete flip around from
what we've been getting with most of
these comic book movies where we see a
teaser trailer like a year year and a
half ahead of the release of the film
that this movie's coming out this year
we finally have our first trailer and I
like it this is obviously just a teaser
and it is very much constructed like a
teaser feels like it easier we don't get
a lot of story we get glimpses of
character we get glimpses of vibe and
general feel and what I see I like word
I can't I had in my head coming away
from this thing was trippy and you know
what Doctor Strange should be trippy and
I like to have a kind of built up to it
too because you know you had the
narration from Tilda Swinton as the
ancient one like you there are young
Lee's multiple realities I'm like cool
nice starting place then she's sort of
like punches him and forcibly astral
projection out of his body I'm like okay
cool makes sense but you know that
astral projection is like that's fairly
straightforward magicky kind of thing
okay and then you see him walking down
this corridor and the things they're
flipping around and realities it's like
rotating it's like a like a shifting
puzzle like that's cool and then sort of
finally we get like New York like
there's new york up here in New York
over here and it's Clark working around
itself and somebody's falling down the
middle and at that point I was like ooh
sold I think they do would like to just
give you a good feel for Stephen strange
there's a lot of emphasis in this teaser
on his hands because that is what drives
him to go and seek out these Metro
things he was a surgeon he was a gifted
surgeon but he lost the feeling in his
hands at an accident and he can't do it
anymore and he's trying to find any way
to fix that so that he can have his
meaning in life again but the ancient
one seems something bigger and more
potential there I like Tilda Swinton as
the angel one I know that was there was
some call of whitewashing because the
ancient one and the comic books is sort
of the classic you know wizened old
young asian looking guy which is fairly
generic and I get the complaint but at
the same time I also really love Tilda
Swinton you shave her head and give her
the monk look I'm going
yeah that's that's really i'm much more
just inherently interested in just
seeing that than I am another ancient
bearded mystic trainer I meet maybe
that's me we get a few other tiny
glimpses of other stuff we get like one
really quick shot of mads mikkelsen
playing whoever he's playing we still
don't really know we get a one-shot I
think of Baron Mordo and he also does
the opening narration i'm fairly certain
and it's done in this sort of i guess
sort of friendly tone it sounds like
he's talking to Stephen strange so I do
get the feeling that they are going to
emphasize the camaraderie between these
two in this movie and if they start
coming you know butting heads it's gonna
be either in the talent or at the very
end so that they can be at each other's
throats in the sequel we'll see how that
pans out about the only thing that
concerns me at all are a few bits we
hear of Benedict Cumberbatch himself
speaking of Stephen strange and that's
the accent he does appear to be doing an
American accent which I'm principal I
like because Stephen strange should not
be grown up Harry Potter he should be a
more homegrown kind of character to for
the u.s. you know you should be taking
influences from his mentality from you
know the American sources Houdini the
traveling mystics who you know used to
go with carnivals and stuff like that
not Merlin but at the same time I'm not
sure I actually really love this accent
something that's bad it sounds what it
sounds a bit like Hugh Laurie doing
house actually which I mean again
british guy who did a very convincing
American accent for a long time but I
think part of the reason that's not
selling you so much this time is because
I know Benedict Cumberbatch's voice
really well and so I I really like his
normal speaking voice so it might take
me a little while to get on board with
this accent I can't decide if I actually
think the accent is bad or if it's just
I'm not used to it yet it could grow on
me I could get used to it it could be
fine but it's the one thing in the trail
that I was coming yeah not so sure
everything else I really like and what I
really hope is that the stuff we saw is
just this is all early stuff this is
just the tip of the iceberg for how
bizarre and weird that this thing can
get and that is the feeling that I
really good cuz I mean added strangest
was that sort of you know three New York
thing and the character falling and that
cuts from that too um Doctor Strange
landing
you know in just the training room with
the ancient one so the implication being
this is just him being shown all these
possibilities then he just lands right
back where he started so that to me and
they're certainly framing it like this
is just where we start from it's gonna
get weirder from here and that is what I
want out of a Doctor Strange movie so
the doctor strange trailer have you seen
it what you think about it whatever you
thought drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe follow me on
twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcast on itunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned